c'est fait ce qui n'augure et
ce qui cube c'est avant tout un
accélérateur de croissance
un accélérateur de contact des changes
et en même temps on les aide à monter
leur prototype ares a répondu avoir créé
une entreprise quel statut juridique
où trouver les moyens financiers
[Musique]
c'était le 8 décembre 2016
d'inauguration du ski cube le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines se doter
d'un incubateur depuis quatre ans
l'accompagnement des entreprises ne
cessent d'évoluer ici sur ce site et
pour en parler nous sommes avec jean luc
berho bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
directeur du ski cube quelles sont les
nouveautés ici au niveau de
l'accompagnement des start-up depuis la
rentrée 2020 alors je parlerai de
nouveautés dans le contexte actuel avec
le co vide qui effectivement nous a
obligés contraint à revoir un peu notre
stratégie et à prioriser d un certain
nombre d'actions le contexte n'étant
évidemment pas favorable à la création
et développement des entreprises
aujourd'hui nous avons ciblé nos actions
plutôt dans l'accompagnement ou la
prévention des difficultés et
l'accompagnement des entreprises qui
elles peuvent rentrer dans des
situations complexes et quel bilan vous
faites déjà depuis le déconfinement sur
cet aspect là alors on a senti à l'issue
du déconfinement une reprise notamment
sur la création d'entreprise avec des
chiffres plutôt encourageants
malheureusement depuis une ou deux
semaines on voit un ralentissement
s'amorcer ce qui peut être source
d'inquiétude pour nous il ya aussi la
french tech paris saclay qui se
développe et qui dans laquelle vous êtes
intégré maintenant bien sûr ça fait
partie des bonnes nouvelles de cette
période de cette période puisque notre
incubateur a été reconnue et valorisée
dans le cadre du dispositif
effectivement que vous mentionniez donc
c'est un élément important pour nous
d'abord parce que effectivement ça mon
truc le travail qu'on a pu mener durant
ces dernières années est connue et
reconnue aujourd'hui
et puis ça veut dire aussi que ce
dispositif va nous permettre de
d'élargir un peu notre recherche de
start up et puis faire intégrer dans
notre incubateur de start up qui
n'auraient peut-être pas eu cette
occasion là si nous n'avions pas été
labellisés alors justement c'est
l'actualité c'est le 2 novembre que vous
vous lancer l'appel à candidatures pour
la prochaine promotion de start up qui
veulent intégrer le ski-club vous
attendez quoi par rapport à cet enfant
alors pour nous c'est une phase
importante parce que
ce que nous appelons la phase 2 de
l'incubateur de 50 ans d'evelyne nous
avons souhaité dans cette période
modifier un peu élargir un peu notre
notre panel de services proposés et nous
étions jusqu'à présent plutôt dans un
accompagnement généraliste avec un
prestataire unique et donc nous avons
choisi pour les trois années qui
viennent de prendre appui également sur
des experts du prestataire experts donc
le champ de compétences qu'on va
proposer dans notre incubateur être va
être beaucoup plus large et on espère
que nous permettra évidemment de
d'accompagner des entreprises sur
d'autres modalités aussi puis un sujet
extrêmement important
on parle incubation c'était vrai
compagnon les startups en amont du
projet mais nous avons décidé aussi de
lancer une ce que nous appelons nous
dans notre jargon un dispositif
d'accélération avec un prestataire le
prestataire l'historique du plateau de
saclay pour accompagner les entreprises
qui ont déjà amorcé du chiffre
d'affaires mais pour justement les
accompagner pour aller plus loin plus
vite dans le développement de leurs
activités
donc on est sur deux types
d'accompagnement des entreprises très en
amont leurs projets mais également les
entreprises qui elles ont déjà commencé
à créer et développer de leurs activités
merci jean luc berho je vous en prie
directeur du ski club l'incubateur du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines